should we start with with the point that
i was making to the channel in fact
let's let's let's start with the broad
brush stuff instead you sat in the
opposite rishi sunak yesterday squint
and a lot of what he announced look
pretty similar uh to what labour have
been proposing for for several months i
mean imitation's the sincerest form of
flattery
well it is clear where the ideas in
british politics are coming from today
and that is from the labour party
because as you know and as i've spoken
to you on this program many times the
labour party been calling for a windfall
tax on those extraordinary profits that
north sea oil and gas companies are
making for months now and the chancellor
and the prime minister have resisted it
at every stage yesterday they bowed to
the inevitable and did that 180 degree
u-turn is hugely welcome because we both
know that there are lots of people
really struggling many people who have
had sleepless nights pensioners that are
worried about turning on the heating
because they don't know how they're
going to pay the bills moms and dads who
don't know how they're going to pay for
the new school uniform because there's
just not that money there when bills are
going through the roof so it's welcome i
i welcome the fact that the government
have adopted labour's policies
well the the chancellor fred's part
would say well look it's not quite a
carbon copy of your policy for one thing
it's not a one-off as it stands this
will go on for two and a half years will
run to the end of the parliament he can
change that but in addition of course i
mean this is it's a lot of money it is a
huge amount of money do you think the
way in which it is being distributed it
was something we talked about with the
chancellor do you think that that is
entirely fair i don't think it's
entirely fair
why don't you take his point but do you
take his point if you want to get the
money out there quickly let me give you
an example it is not right that if you
own a second or a third home you should
get this 400 payment multiple times you
could have a situation where somebody
who's incredibly wealthy gets 400 pounds
on three or four occasions because they
own so many properties that's more than
some of the most vulnerable people in
the country get and this is because this
is all rushed through the government
have been resisting this you've got the
chancellor's own deputy said he only
knew about it the night before there are
no
no forecasts you usually get an office
of budget responsibility forecast when
you have big spending and borrowing
announcements like that it was rushed
through and as a result there are things
in it that just shouldn't be there like
this multiple payments to some of the
wealthiest people but again the point
that the chancellor makes is if you want
to make sure that we get this money out
there you know you have a toss up we can
try and put together a system that would
targeted at the people most in need but
that would take time to put together or
you can do it this way there's a degree
of truth to that isn't there well if the
government hadn't have been resisting
labour's calls for a win for tax and
this additional support for months the
government could have taken the time to
get this package right instead i think
the timing of this package owes more to
sue gray than it does to the economics
and the contents of it owe more to labor
than it do to
conservative uh thinking so the
government need to make sure that every
pound of taxpayers money is spent wisely
we've already seen billions of pounds
written off by this government in fraud
for example we don't want to see
taxpayers money being used to subsidize
some of the richest people when some
people need that additional support so
there's areas of this where we need to
look into but overall of course i
welcome what we've been calling for
which was a windfall tax to help people
with their extraordinary bills right now
so you agree with rishi sunak's
assertion that this will have a minimal
effect on inflation
well look the problem is is because this
was rushed out we haven't had i think
i thought it was your plan it was your
plan you'd presumably have looked at
this as well well look we haven't got
those independent
evaluations of the office of budget
responsibility because this government
have cobbled this uh together at the
last minute what i want to see and i
think what was missing yesterday i think
this goes to the point is a longer-term
strategy
to deal with some of the underlying
problems in our economy so for example
one practical thing that government
could have done yesterday would have
been to announce a whole
package around home insulation to take
money off people's bills not through a
one-off payment but through making their
home more energy efficient to save
hundreds of pounds not just for one year
but years into the future my big worry
is that we could be back here in exactly
the same place next year because the
government aren't getting to grip with
some of the economic security and
stability uh issues some of the
post-brexit post-covered war issues that
are affecting our supply chains and
doing more uh to get those long-term
measures in place to have a stronger and
more secure economy but on the on the
point of inflation that clearly the
treasury will have looked at this
clearly the labor party will have looked
at it when you are costing your own
policy
do you believe that this will have
anything more than a minimal effect on
inflation okay did your plan have
anything other than a minimal infection
i am worried about giving money to
people who don't necessarily need it so
there's multiple payments to some of the
richest people you know they don't need
that money that means additional
spending in the economy i don't think
that is why that's why i think it should
be targeted at those people who need it
most and then you would have less impact
on inflation that is why
targeting does make a difference because
it's about paying for the day-to-day
essentials not just loads more demands
swirling around in the economy but look
you know people need help paying their
bills now that is absolutely essential
but the government do need to address
some of these longer-term problems
otherwise we will just carry on lurching
from crisis to crisis to crisis without
any idea about how to address the fact
that at the moment we have the highest
inflation in the g7 next year the
international monetary fund so that we
will have both the highest inflation and
the lowest growth the government have
got to address these big underlying
challenges that we are facing in britain
more than in other countries around the
world
the head of the ifs quoted in the times
this morning is saying you know this
would be a this would have been a
statement that gordon brown as
chancellor would have been proud of
because of how redistributivist it was i
mean would you agree with that
assessment well as i say the package of
measures uh yesterday owes more to the
labour party than it does to
conservative thinking i'm not going to
uh criticize a package of measures which
asks the the companies that are making
huge profits and using that money to
keep people's bills down but i would say
the chancellor and if i was chancellor i
would want to make sure i was accounting
for every pound of taxpayers money spent
and giving tens of millions of pounds to
people who owned second times is not a
good use of taxpayers money and we know
that the borrowing implications of
yesterday's announcement
looked to be 10 billion pounds this year
and if you're going to be using 10
billion pounds of future taxpayers money
you've got to ensure that you're getting
value for money and i'm not certain that
that's happening which is why we want to
see those independent numbers verifying
and setting out exactly what the
government is spending and on who indeed
the other big concern though about
windfall taxes of this measure is that
it will restrict investment and that was
a complaint that was made about your
plan it's been a a point that has been
made by the head of bp of all
organizations about what we heard from
the chancellor yesterday isn't there a
real risk as we try to sort out our
energy securities we try to sort out our
energy strategy as we try to bring every
last drop of the black stuff out of the
north sea that were actually you know
limiting at the possibility of
organizations like bp doing that
incredibly costly nazi exploration well
the chief executive of bp has said that
a windfall tax
wouldn't change their investment
decisions and it's clear to see why that
they're they're saying they're looking
again at them i think they are reviewing
them now
things have changed since he appeared in
front of the select committee we're now
talking in response to what we heard
from the chancellor yesterday well when
labour said how is plans to room for tax
they said it wouldn't affect their
long-term investment decisions and you
can see why that is the case because you
make a decisions for the long term not
based on uh extraordinary profits that
are being made in uh one year but the
whole
outlook and so i wouldn't expect this to
affect investment decisions but where do
we want the investment we want
investment in nuclear and in renewables
because we know that is the cheapest
form of electricity we also know
we're going to take advantage of the
reserves that we have in the north sea
are you and for to get those we need
exploration we need investment and
that's a short-term business decision
not a long-term business decision for bp
well there's one thing government could
be doing is ending its effective
moratorium on onshore wind it's the
cheapest form of energy and we could be
getting going with that now creating
good quality jobs here in the uk
building those turbines here doing
carbon capture and storage getting on
with the stalled nuclear investment
those are practical things government
can be doing to boost our energy
security less reliant on oil and gas
which are big polluters and also meaning
that we are less reliant on imports from
russia qatar and elsewhere we need that
investment to create those good quality
jobs here in britain